bonsoir à tous merci de nous rejoindre
alors cette semaine dans le kiosque
nous ferons un voyage dans le temps
direction les années 70 à l'occasion de
la visite d'un appartement reconstitué
enfin nicolas gervais nous présentera la
nouvelle saison du théâtre de
billancourt mais pour l'heure place à
notre invité les vacances d'été
approchent et il vous manque peut-être
des idées de lecture en effet quoi de
mieux qu'un bon livre pour se détendre
ça tombe bien nous recevons ce soir un
romancier
bonsoir 2 et senio bons soins alors vous
êtes professeur de français vous avez
publié trois romans alors avant qu'on
parle de chacun d'eux déjà pour un peu
mieux vous connaître
qu'est ce qui vous a donné envie
d'écrire qu'est ce qui vous a amené à
l'écriture c'est assez compliqué de
répondre à cette question parce que j'ai
plusieurs
motivation déjà je voulais partager des
aventures avec les lecteurs moi quand je
lis quand je regarde un film quand quand
je dis 'mon dessinée c'est vrai que je
me dis que c'est génial de pouvoir faire
rêver les lecteurs le spectateur et donc
du coup une première motivation c'est
vraiment essayé de faire rêver les gens
et deuxième motivation
je pense que c'est de faire découvrir
des sujets ou faire réfléchir sur des
sujets c'est vrai que je fais quelque
chose depuis l'enfance vous y pensiez
vous feront plus tard c'est vrai que
quand j'étais plus jeune mais quand
j'étais adolescent j'écrivais mais j'ai
fait des bombes et des demi page
d'histoire puis c'est fini c'est la
poubelle
je m'étais essayer faire une bande
dessinée bon j'avais pas dessiner donc
j'ai passé assez vite mais ça que
j'aimais déjà raconté l'histoire du
moins dans ma tête et puis c'est de les
faire admettre à l'écrit mais ça pas
vraiment marché ne peut pas facile
pourtant voilà apparemment le
français au collège c'était était
complice avec le collège je les ai
beaucoup à côté mais c'était ma lecture
personnelle en fait je lisais je
m'appelle mais ce que je disais mais
beaucoup de de huy de romont
scientifique de 10 et beaucoup d'afro
mais qui ont ainsi mais je les ai pas
vraiment ce qu'on me donnait dans le
programme donc du coup ça crée un
décalage entre moi et le collège et
c'est après que j'ai commencé à voir ce
n'était pas aussi finalement écrire ce
que vous prouviez pas aussi forcément
envie de donner envie au travers
d'histoires qu'on peut ne compte trouve
pas habituellement
ah oui voilà c'est ça ça va je me suis
dit c'est mon premier roman que j'ai
écrit plus pour les adolescents je me
suis dit ça pourrait être intéressant de
décret est une histoire qui soit
vraiment pour les adolescents alors on
va en parler vraiment ce premier roman
il s'appelle au jour le jour
sorti en 2008 ça s'adresse à des
adolescents et vous y parlez de violence
et de l'influent justement chez les
jeunes racontez-nous quelles étaient vos
intentions parce qu'à une sorte de
double lecture 1 c'est ce que vous
disiez tout à l'heure vous avez envie de
d'amener les gens à se poser des
questions donc là sept camions à la
partie réflexion et sur un fond d'
aventure c'est ça exactement bah voila
mon premier roman qui ici comme je les
écris je me suis dit j'aimerais bien à
côté histoire pour aux adolescents mais
ça se passe dans l'indicé et je pense
que poser adolescents ça peut être une
aventure vraiment super parce qu'ils
vont se reconnaître vraiment dans dans
les personnages il ya de l'action il ya
de l'amour la haine la trahison
exactement voilà je démontre les
relations humaines
la psychologie de chaque personnage
l'évolution aussi les ambitions de
chacun par rapport aux autres et je
pense que cette aventure peut plaire
beaucoup d'adolescents aussi aux adultes
sains et mais j'ai fait exprès du mètre
1 que tout ça soit vrai soit reposée sur
sur une réflexion justement sur
l'analyse sur des jeunes voilà la quête
de la pas pu arrêter l'influencent
engrenage violence
le système scolaire mine de rien si
c'est un peu plus en font mais il ya
quand même pas mal de petits éléments
que je sais c'est pas possible
excusez moi que je glisse à gauche à
droite sur des réflexions sur sur le
système scolaire les jeunes dans ce
milieu là et je pense que cette double
lecture permet vraiment au jour le jour
2 d'accrocher les jeunes d'accrocher les
moins jeunes et d'ivoire chacun
exactement g20 eu des retours de
d'adolescents qui m'ont dit qu'on a
adoré parce que vraiment ils sont
reconnus et j'ai eu des retours par
exemple de personnes plus âgées de deux
hommes deux femmes qui ont trouvé très
intéressant justement comment j'ai mis
en scène ces adolescents en fait c'est
ce que j'ai montré avec ces adolescents
alors justement par une mise en scène ça
c'est aussi une de vos spécificités dans
votre style d'écriture vous avez cette
vision cinématographique en fait
exactement ça que moi ce que j'aime
c'est montrer j'aime bien montrer des
actions en fait j'aime bien créer de
l'émotion à travers ce qu'on voit ce
qu'on pense ce qu'on ressent en fête et
du coup c'est vrai que j'ai une écriture
assez on m'a souvent dit ça assez
cinématographique
on a l'impression de voir un film quant
aux livres romans beaucoup de gens m'ont
ont fait cette remarque en fait et je me
suis rendu compte qu à force de devoir
cette remarque effectivement tu quand
j'écris je visualise tellement ce que je
vais écrire
est ce que j'ai envie de faire passer
comme émotion que finalement ben le
lecteur le ressent aussi sept buts 1
alors deuxième roman dont on va parler
ses créations voilà
c'est le premier tome d'une trilogie
intitulé l'enfer et sur terre donc c'est
plutôt un thriller fantastique ça
pouvait aller donner nous ont vivement
de lire racontée par creatio il a rien à
voir avec au jour le jour c'est vraiment
un autre style fantastique vous propose
de lire la quatrième de couverture
c'est très parlant ok donc au milieu de
l'amazonie dans les tréfonds de la terre
dans un secret sur l'origine de la vie
et des dieux qui va de boue qui
bouleverseront notre mission du monde
victime d'un accident au coeur de cette
jungle un groupe de vacanciers va
attendre indéfiniment les seconds les
secours avant d'être contraint de
s'enfuir
alors en fait on est là encore une fois
dans l'idée d'une aventure des
survivants dans la colonie et vous y
inclut aussi la dimension de réflexion
là encore sur l'existence en fait
l'existence existence de dieu
exactement bah en fait comment vous êtes
faibles etc tueur là on à côté aventure
clairement ont donc et des survivants
dingue comment survivre comment ne pas
perdre la tête celle au milieu de cette
jungle
comment se nourrir quels sont les
tensions qui ont être peu à peu entre
les survivants
mais aussi une réflexion et au bout d'un
moment ils vont tomber sur quelque chose
et j'ai pas envie d'en dire trop qui qui
vont leur montrer notre vision du monde
et toute la trilogie de ce qu'on appelle
donc l'enfer sur terre
toute cette trilogie le premier c'est
creatio de deuxième ce sera pandore il
sortira fin d'année je pense est le
troisième il sortira l'an prochain ça
entretient chaque tome aborde une
question sur les origines le premier
c'est de les origines de de dieu d'où
elle revient dur la bordée d'un point de
vue scientifique se sent flatté qu'ils
ont une religion
voilà je n'attaque pas le rejoint
spécialement je me suis dis bah
j'aimerais bien qu'on que chacun en fait
réfléchir sur sa manière de voir dieu
donc voilà le côté réflexion et moi en
fait qui suit qui ait une vision assez
scientifique du monde
je pense que les scientifiques y arrive
à décrire comment d'où vient enfin
comment marche la vie comme on march
l'univers l'astronomie de la physique et
c'est les mathématiques mais après je me
suis posé la question mais pourquoi tout
ça en fait pourquoi la vie pourquoi donc
c'est plutôt philosophique c'est
philosophique mais chacun y trouvera ses
rêves simplement voilà vrai que j'aime
au ce que je montre j'ai pas voulu ce
que je montre c'est vraiment une image
de la réalité en fait c'est et chacun
peut traduire cette image comme ils le
souhaitent et donc le premier tome 3 est
une question sur des origines de dieu
dernier roman est carrément qu'on va
pouvoir découvrir alors là c'est un
autre style d'écriture c'est tentation
alors là sur la quatrième de couverture
vous dites qu'il s'agit d'une histoire
tirée d'un rêve
ensuite vous avez commencé parce que
c'est vrai voilà où est ce que c'est
pour attirer les lecteurs
alors en fait avec une tentation c'est
le sait le serment il est là ne passe
vraiment à part dans un coin de mur
voilà c'est ça en fait il n pas
totalement totalement à part dans mes
romans d'habitude mes romans je les
conçois l'avant je conçois histoire jeu
j'avais fait des trams j'écris soit
d'autres feuilles les idées tentation il
ya c'est une histoire qui est venu à moi
je j'ai fait un rêve de martin luther
king
vraiment c'est une histoire qui avait
une début un début une paix rhdp
situation initiale enfin jusqu'à la fin
des mouvements et je me suis arrivé je
me suis dit il faut que j'écrive et donc
qu'à ce moment là j'étais en train
d'écrire pandore qu'est la suite de
creatio j'ai arrêté la lecture de
pandore pour absolument je voulais
absolument mettre soi écrit cette saison
et rêve
jérôme ans et j'ajoute et pas mal
d'éléments que je trouvais intéressant
dans cette histoire et ç'a donné
tentation est grande de semaine ont fait
un livre qui est écrit à la première
personne tentation ça m'a beaucoup
appris en fait vraiment beaucoup appris
le fait d'écrire la première personne ça
m'a vraiment libéré dans l'écriture je
pouvais écrire comme je voulais et plus
de contraintes
déjà je n'ai pas de contrat de
l'histoire monsieur comme s'est étirée
d'un d'un rêve on bat l'histoire et
l'escale elle est venue à moi j'ai pas
besoin de réfléchir dessus et en plus le
fait d'écrire à 20 personnes
j'ai pas de contraintes de langage et du
coup j'ai pu vraiment marcher et faire
comme je voulais et ça m'a vraiment ça
m'a beaucoup soient les lecteurs ce que
j'ai voulu faire est ce que les retours
j'ai donc dû maintien c'est intéressant
que ça a marché c'est que les gens se et
beaucoup les lecteurs sont beaucoup plus
impliqués dans l'histoire
et il a fallu entre eux électeurs et
j'ai plusieurs éléments que je vais en
scène dans le roman pour justement que
la barrière entre le le personnage
électeurs soit quasiment brisé en fait
soit et donc du coup c'est ça que je
voulais faire c'est que chaque lecteur
finalement quand il faut ce personnage à
gien réfléchi à ce qui lui arrive
interagir avec le monde extérieur
finalement eux mêmes et se poser la
question du maintien moi qu'est ce que
j'aurais fait comment je verrai la chose
en fait en tout cas pour retrouver ses
trois romans
direction le site internet qui s'affiche
merci mon compte et merci à vous et si
on faisait à présent un saut dans le
temps un voyage même à guyancourt pour
marquer le 40e anniversaire du quartier
du pont du rotois les habitants ont eu
la chance de vivre un véritable retour
vers le futur
les images de david carpentier mobilier
gonflable couleurs et formes improbables
pas de doux nous avons remonté le temps
où le plastique et la bakélite 30
irruption dans notre quotidien et
révolutionne même nos modes de
consommation
bienvenue dans les années soixante dix à
l'occasion des 40 ans du quartier du
pont du rotois rallions cours la ville
propose à ses habitants de revivre un
moment d'histoire à travers la
reconstitution partielle d'un
appartement de l'époque dans cet
appartement on peut donc découvrir
toutes les pièces qui contiennent des du
mobilier qui donc caractéristiques de
ces années là c'est plus une évocation
des années 70 une reconstitution
réaliste réalisé grâce aux collections
du musée de la ville de saint quentin en
yvelines
les visites ont permis aux nostalgiques
de redécouvrir l'esthétique
caractéristiques de la fin des trente
glorieuses et d'initier les plus jeunes
aux tendances coloré
on a reçu évidemment beaucoup de classe
de toutes ces écoles de guyancourt qui
ont pu découvrir donc tout son mobilier
toutes ses formes ses couleurs qui sont
vraiment celle que de cons connu leurs
parents voire leurs grands parents
et donc cette exposition leur a permis
vraiment de s'initier à cette esthétique
et et puis aussi de retrouver voilà des
le côté ludique du design de l'époque la
fois esthétique et pratique il ya des
motifs qui sont vraiment très
caractéristique et qui les ont frappés
parfois ces enfants avaient vraiment
envie de retrouver de vivre dans cet
appartement
donc finalement l'esthétique ludique et
colorée
a été vraiment très les a les a
enchantés pour la plupart et ils étaient
très réceptifs en tout cas on a eu de
très bons retours puisque les habitants
du quartier ont pu ont eu la chance de
retrouver donc ses archives à travers
les films avec on se retrouve parfois
même dans ses films
des proches et donc ça fait partie voilà
d'une histoire l'histoire d'un quartier
c'est l'histoire d'une presque une
grande famille en quelque sorte
cette semaine l'association art en tête
organisé un stage de sculpture aux
granges de l'abbaye de port royal des
champs
mathilde capbern et juliette poussons
ont suivi les stagiaires dans leur
découverte de la taille de pierre
josette est à son quatrième stage de
sculpture
elle s'inspire cette fois ci d'une
statue d'un sculpteur peu connu devenue
experte du burin et du marteau elle
tente malgré tout de définir les
qualités nécessaires pour tailler la
pierre
peut-être un petit sens artistique c'est
vrai que la dimension en 3d on n'y est
pas très habitués on peut dessiner on
peut vous voir vos beaucoup d'image on
est un siècle d'image mais le 3d c'est
voir à la fois vu du au vu de derrière
et c'est que tout soit soit plausible en
quelque sorte un travail qui demande du
temps
une bonne semaine pour finir cette
statue pas besoin d'être un
professionnel pour participer à l'un de
ces stages c'est avant tout un moment de
convivialité et de rencontre mais pas
seulement
c'est le temps où il se met à part une
laissent leurs activités pour venir
écouter c'est une c'est aussi
un loisir de réalisation de soi de
sculpter puisse et pérenne une sculpture
bon lâché soir où la garder au temple à
mettre à l'extérieur et c'est sans doute
ce que ça plaît vendredi 5 juillet les
apprentis sculpteurs exposeront leurs
oeuvres aux granges de port royal des
champs à magny les hameaux
nicolas gervais a rencontré cette
semaine
yoann lavabre le directeur de la ferme
de bel ébat à guyancourt et nous
présente sa nouvelle saison
saviez vous que l'on pouvait danser sur
les musiques d'alain bashung saviez-vous
qu'à aiguille en cours et il existe
trois journées de festival pendant
lesquels le public grandit du matin
jusqu'au soir non et bien yoann lavabre
le directeur de la ferme de bel ébat
vous explique tout vous présentons sa
saison s'est tout de suite dans le
kiosque
c'est une saison comme tout comme toutes
les saisons de la ferme de bel ébat avec
accès sur la création la création c'est
évidemment très important au coeur de
cette programmation puisque c'est une
vingtaine de spectacles sur les sur les
et c'est également cette résidence de
création
donc voilà c'est vraiment la marque de
fabrique du lieu qu'elle soit
nani n'a pas vrai que l'année charmante
non na li ne parlez pour vous protéger
taquet laurie répondait donc jean moi ne
me riendeau
j'aime
sécu pierre boulez mon père m'a laissé
trois beaux journaux de terre
c'est pour elle tout es tu content
journaux tout mon savoir et tout le
théâtre contemporain bien entendu mais
avec également des ouvertures sur toutes
les autres disciplines que ce soit la
danse que ce soit évidemment la poésie
la marionnette
il ya beaucoup de marionnettes cette
saison c'est comme ça mais également
l'opéra ce qu'on aura deux opéras dont
un qui sera en résidence de création à
l'opéra jazz d'isabelle olivier qui est
donc une harpiste compositrice un opéra
inspiré du baron perché qui s'appelle
don't worry be harpie
oh
depuis trois ans la ferme de bel ébat
maintient cet engagement en proposant
autant de spectacles écrits par des
femmes que par des hommes et mis en
scène par des femmes que par des hommes
elle est en force son ce sont évidemment
les sept résidences de création et les
trois journées consacrées aux traditions
et arts populaires que sont le cirque le
conte et la marionnette
donc ce sont nos journées festivalière
qu'est ce que c'est que ce cirque et
qu'est ce que tu racontes c'est de la
manipulation qui auront lieu au mois
d'octobre au mois de décembre et au mois
de mai le principe c'est de prendre une
discipline donc par exemple le cirque
plus précisément le clown
le compte est la marionnette est de
faire grandir le spectateur au fil des
heures
donc on commence avec des propositions
pour les tout petits parfois même à
partir de 1 an
le samedi matin à partir de 11 heures et
puis ensuite à 14h30 on va s'adresser à
un public un tout petit peu plus âgée à
partir de 6 ans 7 ans et à 18 heures à
un public familial beaucoup plus large à
partir de 8 ans ou de dix ans pour tout
le monde
blanche
et pouf en demandant pourquoi tu pleures
jamais les pieds dans l'eau tu veux toi
doha après demain ça sera contente
3 j'en suis sûr
tu pourrais vous parler d'apache d'hamid
ben mahi et un spectacle de danse hip
hop qui croise l'univers musical de
bashung
on va réaccueillir joël pommerat à la
ferme de bel ébat et vous savez que la
ferme de bel ébat a été une étape
importante dans le parcours de cet
immense auteur metteur en scène le
spectacle beaucoup plus intimiste comme
maman dans le vent de jacques des cordes
qui a une très très belle réalisation
naninne de voltaire une mise en scène
très originale autour d'un texte oublié
aujourd'hui d'une grande vitalité
voilà mais y'en a vraiment beaucoup et
moi je peux pas choisir
voilà pour la ferme de bel ébat et
maintenant je vous laisse avec aurélia
je vous dis à la saison prochaine à
bientôt on va relier à beaune été très
bien la coupe la super nous sommes
mercredi découvrons à présent vos
sorties ciné au micro de jonathan vilma
le casting est plutôt intéressant mais
l'histoire réchauffe un peu sur ma faim
j'ai trouvé un mode histoire un peu
légère film très sympa j'aime bien les
personnages caisse grossman emma
thompson c'était très agréable c'est
vraiment excellent c'est c'est drôle
c'est plein d'émotions c'est plein
d'action c'est c'est vraiment une suite
excellemment réussi je pense que c'est
un film qui est tout public
et puis acta mais aussi de l'émotion
dans les filles très bientôt treize
enfants et encore le père meurt mais
très bien ça dépend des effets spéciaux
et des aventures très bien j'ai beaucoup
aimé surtout quand il ya le gros dragon
qui a craqué c'est tout j'aime les
westerns les paysages de western et puis
il ya beaucoup d'humour et c'est très
bien allez je vous propose à présent
d'autres idées de sorties ces prochains
jours et pourquoi pas une balade à vélo
sur les traces du roi soleil alors avec
cette balade le musée de la ville vous
entraîne à la découverte de l'ancien
réseau d'étangs d'adultes da que du
pardon et de rigoles de louis xiv et
c'est donc samedi à partir de 11h pensez
à réserver auprès du musée de la ville
cette année encore le quartier du
buisson à magny les hameaux va s'animer
du 7 au 13 juillet à l'occasion de
l'opération remets tes tongs
les ateliers artistiques des défis
sportifs des activités manuelles seront
proposées pour toute la famille rendez
vous sur le site internet pour retrouvez
tout le programme détaillé voilà notre
émission est à présent terminé merci de
nous avoir suivis je vous retrouve donc
la semaine prochaine à 18h30 à mercredi